ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we are here
saturday night for you every week
saturday night or sunday morning
whenever you are
coming across this broadcast um
i'm watching my friend's bulldog my
friend got uh
he had a baby he had a baby and he
texted me and said are you in la
and i was because i was performing at
whitney cummings uh
stand-up show that she had in her
driveway
we'll talk about that in a moment and um
i had said i would do it i said i'd take
the dog when you had a baby i said when
the
when the baby comes i'll take the dog
you don't think anyone's gonna actually
remember these things you say but you
say them in the hopes that people will
forget about them
and then disappear from your life but uh
because that didn't happen i had to
honor my commitment
so he is here and we will bring him uh
we'll get him on screen eventually but
uh we're gonna just
so we we may have to just you may see us
our eyes darting around the room because
these bulldogs is like a little
hippopotamus
it's like a little pig and uh
it just uh destroys everything i mean
they can't procreate they ca they can
barely breathe they can't
walk i mean it's it's uh amazing and i
was on the phone ray comrade comes like
that's a pig
i'm like what yeah a lot of things
disgusting put it down
what do you think people say about you
by the way i i want to say and i don't
always you know people sometimes notice
something i'm in that's not this show
um and i and i and i appreciate that you
know i don't announce all of my projects
and the things i do here but sometimes
there are fans
uh of me that will recognize me and go
hey you were in that you know i was on
the danny uh
that show with uh the rapper why am i
blanking oh you played danny brown
danny brown i played peeper of the
telescope on the danny brett get off the
bed
don't [ __ ] with the book and
just get him yeah he's gonna rip it open
just move the book
please i mean
just relax
just stop doing everything you're doing
just let him on the bed
ben just let him on the bed let him
sleep
danny brown i played peeper the
telescope and it was a great honor to do
that i liked danny brown a lot
it was a funny it's a funny show the
dialogue was funny
um and now people have noticed me
uh in the new netflix film cuties
and it's been an honor to be in that and
it's just
such a a real treat i am one of the
cuties
and i play a young woman who
is being exploited sexually
and uh people are in arms about it
they're up in arms about it
uh i've not seen this kurt metzger my
friend i was talking to him last night
and he said
this is an intersectional car crash
because you have uh a woman of color
director
who's trying to i guess shed light on
the idea that young girls are being
exploited sexually
but how did they shed light on the idea
that young girls were being exploited
sexually
by sexually exploiting young girls
so supposedly the last scene in this
film is so disturbing
and such clear like bait for pedophiles
that it's so absurd that there's
nationwide campaigns
cancel netflix people are
canceling netflix which i thought i saw
cancelled netflix i just i have to do it
jenny slate
but no it's it's cuties i'm kidding love
jenny in the whole uh squad
um but cuties have you seen
cuties not seen it yet you're lying
you've been watching cuties
that's a real sick by the way how
sick is it like that's the real [ __ ]
somebody calls you and they're like hey
i uh
i found a movie on netflix is great you
might want to check it out
what's it called cuties by the way the
name
sounds like a dark web cp website
cuties and the marketing for the thing
is not good like the marketing for it is
not like we're shedding light on the
issue of
exploitation of miners the marketing for
it is like look at these
[ __ ] twerk that's the problem
the problem is the marketing is like
it's female empowerment yes queen
i'm 11 years old and here's my [ __ ]
and it's like whoa whoa
i mean the marketing for this is out of
control why does that girl in the back
kind of look like val kilmer
the point is this terrifying
this is not appropriate get it off the
screen just show it for a minute we
don't want to have this
let's not have that be the backdrop
please god only knows
the point is that people are angry
justifiably
at cuties shapiro ben shapiro could take
on it where he was like
the message is getting lost kind of in
the marketing of the film
because i think the marketing of the the
inter you have so many different
you know buzzwords here going on it's
like female empowerment
and then also like exploitation so it's
like you have these young
scantily clad miners in doing very
sexually suggestive dances
on netflix this is the set is about to
come down
the set is about to come down
are you hold on i'm gonna get him hold
on
hold on
this is the producer of cuties this is
why
he's trying to destroy the show stand up
now sit sit
please sit sit
down sit
have you seen cuties is this why you're
trying to destroy the show do you have
any respect for anything
when he first met oscar oscar really
tried to [ __ ] him up
and duncan didn't understand because
duncan didn't understand
he didn't understand that there was evil
in the world until he met oscar
and oscar just tried to attack him for
absolutely no reason
and duncan's just trying to dunk in
duncan it's a
podcast i mean
what is the history of this dog like
these dogs how did they even
come about
it's so crazy but what the point here is
that
cuties is uh are really getting
people angry i've not seen it i don't
really plan on seeing it
i don't plan on seeing cuties
duncan you're a cutie are you now he's
[ __ ] up the sound
you can't do this duncan
911 just came and passed
duncan what do you think about 911
all right you have to get down now have
to get down oh god
he's such a monster hold on hold on
get him down say goodbye ever to
everyone duncan
we got to talk about 911 now duncan
he's so heavy he's so incredibly heavy
everybody you know this girl i'm friends
with on facebook she put a photo with
donald trump up holding a flag and she
goes two days after 9 11. she goes
he'll always get my vote he's always put
america first
and you're like well if that's all we
need to do to secure your vote is to
hold up a flag on the roof of a building
two days after a national tragedy well
then that's
ah he'll never not get my vote
even if he serves two terms and he wants
to serve another one
he'll get my vote because he held a flag
up after 9 11.
by the way one of the funniest things
ever that i've ever seen
there was this tour guide who was like
this old bitter
guy and he was just an angry guy when i
was a tour guide in new york city on
those double-decker buses
and it was the anniversary of 911 and he
got on the bus and like
a british couple had asked about the
heroism of the firefighters
like they were it must have been an
amazing day
maybe they were australian i'll never
get these right some are british and
then
some come out australian but let's say
they were from
the land down under and he was like well
it was real heroes that day
and the guy's response was the best i've
ever heard he goes
he goes that's all a lie he goes i was
downtown
i saw those buildings fall and the cops
are the firemen he goes they ran the
other way
he goes no one ran into those buildings
he goes i watched it
he goes so you can believe whatever lie
you want he goes nobody was running into
those burning buildings they were
running away
they were cowards i swear
the whole bus was just frozen they
didn't know what to do
the guy goes they were cowards they were
running away
and they go i was like oh you just
stayed like some australian guy was just
staring at him like
i'd never heard that and then and then
he said to me this guy
i was training any on on his bus you
know and then he said to me he goes
he goes he goes i'm not lying he goes
they ran away
and i'm like wasn't there
i was in miss rice's history class
in holy trinity diocesan high school
in hicksville new york i was sitting
there
next to a woman named kate butler
who now has another name she was and i
had asked her for a pen or a pencil
because i
always didn't bring a pen or pencil to
school that was my thing i
never i always said for four years i
said do you have a pen
do you have a pencil do you have the
homework you know
what book were you supposed to read i i
i could never handle it
i just was never prepared i did not go
to school prepared
okay unlike this show which has
so much preparation so much show prep i
mean
hours and hours and days and days of
preparation for this program
but i turned around to a kate and they
said you have a pen and before i knew it
and my the teacher was called out of the
room she was brought back in and then
there was
she said there has been a tat there was
an attack on the world trade center
and the pentagon and back then we didn't
you know the world trade center had been
bombed already so we didn't even put it
together
that that was a huge deal and then the
uh
pentagon was the one that made me go wow
this is war
because the pentagon you knew it's like
you know this is the civilian command
center the military civilian
and you know this is the this is the big
one they're hitting the pentagon
so all so i was sitting there and i was
in miss rice's history class and i heard
that
and the first thing i screamed out in
the class i said
inside job they said what i said it's an
inside job
don't you see that i didn't even know
what happened but i just instinctually
said
it's an inside job and then i just
started screaming there are no planes
and what was strange is i didn't even
know that there were planes
he's trying to [ __ ] the chair do you see
what he's trying to do
he's trying to [ __ ] the chair right now
he's just trying to
he's trying to [ __ ] the chair does 911
get you horny duncan
i screamed there were no pl it was sad
you know one of the kids i knew in
school his dad died
really a lot of people's parents i
called my dad so quick i'm like
are you a windows of the world
he's like no what i'm home
i'm like all right see you later
how great would how great would it be to
lose a parent 911.
let's stop pretending that wouldn't have
been the greatest moment in your [ __ ]
life
hey how's pete davidson doing pretty
[ __ ] good
he's not sitting here trying to keep a
bulldog off his set
i tuck by strap both of my parents into
the seats of united 93
if i could have attempted his career so
let's cut the [ __ ]
candlelight vigils where'd mommy go i
don't know bin laden took her where's my
movie
i'm sitting here for years week after
week brilliance
brilliance but i because i don't have a
parent that
died i'll melt my parents right [ __ ] now
judd apatow email me
stop he agrees sparking at the box of
magic spoons he's barking the magic
spoon why because you realize it's a
keto cereal
is that why because it simulates the
experience of the sugar cereals you
liked as a child
is that why you're barking
enough with the the 911 um
porn memorabilia can we stop
that day we were all americans okay
thanks thanks a lot you know that day we
were all americans
that day we were all americans that yes
and the day before
that too and the day after that
but thank you for making that brilliant
point there was a lot of unity in the
early periods after 9 11.
i've discussed it on this show there was
a lot of unity in the early periods
after 9 11 in this country but that
evaporated
pretty quickly and we wanted it to
you don't want a country you don't want
a cult you don't want to live in a call
how are you doing how weird would that
be
shut up how weird would it be
if you just walked around and everybody
was in get him out of the room get him
out of the room now now you're out
now you're out because you can't handle
the responsibility
send them out please
you leave now we're discussing 911 you
have a little respect
put them in the kitchen please
my point is that you don't want to live
in a constant
funeral and all these people that are
just glorifying the immediate aftermath
of 9 11
as if it's the goal as if that's the
goal
to walk around with your head bowed
thinking about your own mortality every
minute of every day it's not the goal
by the way and it was nice for a few
days
a couple of vigils are nice but you
don't want to live in a vigil so can we
stop
please romanticizing this idea
i don't like where we are now clearly
we've gone off the rails quite a bit
culturally in this country but this idea
that everything has to be right after 9
11 when it was so
nice it was nice for a few days
i'm just sick of all these people on
facebook being like well
we were all americans that day people
love talking about other heroic people
people love that they they think it
makes them
heroic by talking about other people
that were heroic
you know remember the heroes
you know
i'm just saying i would have been
willing to sacrifice
more than i sacrificed in 9 11
which was very little i would have been
willing to sacrifice more
and i think it's important that we all
remember that
you know so that's my little commentary
on 9 11. it changed new york
dramatically and i put something up on
instagram about this if you
knew about new york city before 9 11 it
changed new york dramatically
it made new york a victim it made new
york vulnerable and then
you know new york was this tough city
that it was not
nearly as criminal
as it had been it was getting safer but
it was a tough city and then it became
you know uh about um midwestern tourists
coming to save new york city
that's when you had the disney on
broadway start
tourists were coddled and catered to
and it became a city that was very
specific it made it into a very general
city
where everybody can enjoy it that is
what it is
eventually it um you know all the
restaurants in new york city
uh a lot of them were french and a lot
of fine dining
or uh luxury uh was
very opulent in the 90s it was very
frilly there was a lot of lace and big
tablecloths and
bank cats and i mean it looked very like
you were eating in versailles
and then after 9 11 that felt
inappropriate that felt wrong and then
the green market movement started
and you know all these restaurants kind
of made themselves look half done there
was exposed brick and steel and pipes
and it just
you're more connected to your
environment than you had been you wanted
to eat on a wooden table
and things were real and it really
changed new york city if you
if you knew new york city pre-911 many
of you don't
but it really did change new york city
you could take that down but you could
read that if you have any interest in it
um um but it was it was very interesting
in the aftermath of 911 and i'm starting
to see a lot of overlap between that and
and corona a little bit a little overlap
between that
the the constant terrorizing of the
public
has become unfortunate but it was
called by me and other people on the
show who said this is real
this did happen uh 911 happened and
it will be used as a way to constantly
terrify people and to
uh achieve aims that possibly
were being planned long before that
event like
corona like covet so when you have uh dr
fauci
who cannot throw a baseball go out and
tell everybody that we have to hunker
down for the winter
we have to hunker down for the winter
listen to this
guy we should hunker down
we could see a very deadly december
we need to hunker down this fall and
winter
it's not going to be easy says dr
fauci
i'm telling you right now folks we're
getting to a point now
where you're gonna start you're gonna
have to start making your own decisions
about your own life your own ability to
earn money
and the experts are so all in the pocket
of somebody everybody
is in the pocket of somebody and they
have an interest in you believing
certain things and they have an interest
in you walking around
um and not questioning them and i'm not
saying that you should go out there and
be willy-nilly and start
you know taking all kinds of chances
with your health but i am telling you
that i don't know how many young people
this is
killing i don't know that i don't know
i believe that this is still the vast
majority of people that are dying
from this disease are elderly and many
of them may have other conditions
that is still what people are able to
treat this disease a lot better
now and i just don't know if we should
constantly be you know hunkered out we
hunkered down for four months
and then as roseanne said people left
their house when they were ready to kill
the great roseanne i did a podcast with
the great
roseanne an epic meeting of the minds
a legend such as herself and uh
myself having uh a a conversation or
something that would would
get close to that and i was
very honored that she spoke to me she's
so funny she's
effortlessly funny and she makes some
very good points and then she's kind of
in and out of it as well she's getting
older
she said she was close to 80 she's 67
i mean she's not she's nowhere near 80.
but what did you think did you enjoy the
roseanne uh she's such a legend she's so
i was crying off to the side just
laughing she's very very funny man she's
incredibly funny
and uh it's well worth a watch hey
do you take some dmt before that you're
sure
before that interview yeah yeah
you take uh you drink some ayahuasca
before you watch me and her
yeah yeah i think it's a good primer for
that conversation
you might uh put a little tab acid under
the tongue
before before you hit play on that one
because it is a little wild
but it is well worth a watch very
honored to do that
with uh the great roseanne what is an
appropriate gift by the way now that my
friend had this kid
what's an appropriate gift should i get
him what i got you and katie for the
wedding
ben is angry at me but ben is
he's he doesn't believe that i sent him
and his wife a beautiful
wedding present that was lost in the
mail because of covert 19.
it was lost in the mail because of cover
19.
i won't even tell him what it was like
because i don't want him to be so upset
and because if i told him when i got him
he would be so
sad for doubting me he would then
like you know who knows offered to just
work on this show for free for the rest
of his life
because he would be so indebted
to me just because of what i got him
that was lost in the mail
due to uh coronavirus we we cannot find
it we don't know where it is
so but i don't know do you get a savings
bond can you get that
what do you get oh you could do that
like a mutual fund do you invest in this
country though for the kid or do you buy
him something from china
because we're on the way out what's the
savings bond in this country going to be
worth
soon do you really give a kid a bond and
say cash it in went right when you're
about to go to college
when you can't breathe anymore
i'm ready to no longer leave the house
aren't you see in california we've been
getting ready to just not leave anymore
because when you leave there's ash and
embers of dead trees in your throat
so you can't go anywhere and the outside
has now just become a hindrance
for the inside activities you want like
you just can't get on the wi-fi because
the [ __ ]
everything outside's burning and you're
getting angry and cell phone towers are
up in flames so
the outside now it's just annoying the
outside world's annoying
and that's why we're all going digital
we're all going to go into the void
eventually
and we're going to communicate with each
other digitally we're not going to leave
our homes and we're going to get
you're going to get amazon food
deliveries you're going to have uh
pedophile netflix
and you're going to have uh you know
whatever you want
and you're going to be okay you're not
going to want to leave you're going to
go this is fine
this is fine because you know what's the
other option you're gonna go outside
in a full hazmat suit doesn't make any
sense
i'm so ready for that i'm so ready to
just be in a in a good quadrant i hope
i'm in a good quadrant
when they divide the country up into
quadrants based on resources
which will happen soon like district
nine remember that movie yeah yeah i
just hope i'm in the good district i
forget which one that is but that's all
coming true the hunger games and
district nine
all those teeny bopper movies will come
true eventually and you know aoc will be
one of the queens and she'll walk around
you know with a scepter and
you know you'll be like oh she's from
the you know she's district 12
or whatever i mean that's all happening
that's all gonna happen just embrace it
you know
it's really bad in california man i've
never seen it this bad
when you go out now never have never
happened you're just
breathing in it's like a campfire
in your car you're breathing in this air
it's
really truly a problem and then of
course everybody needs to virtue signal
on social media with all their
their photos of like the red skies and
like i guess we should have listened to
that climate change
i was like yeah i guess so but maybe
it's too late now so maybe a shut up
it's too late it's too late it's too
late
you're literally on fire so what does it
matter
i'm glad you scored that point glad you
scored that part
well i guess we shall
is that the last thing you want to do
before you check out is to score a point
score a political point like the last
breath
of of of [ __ ] unsafe oxygen you
breathe on this earth
should be used to get the better of
somebody
who hell i guess i'm
what an american way to go just trying
to best somebody in a pointless online
argument
right before you go magic spoon baby you
know me
i love the sugar cereals hard to kick
the sugar very tough sugar in the carbs
addict addict addict releases that
dopamine in your brain not a lot makes
you happy sugar makes you happy
you think about when you were in a kid
when you were a kid you didn't want to
[ __ ] eat raisin bran you wanted lucky
charms count chocula
the real [ __ ] you know fruit loops you
wanted good [ __ ] waffle crisp
apple jacks [ __ ] everything you
wanted sugar
cereals okay and you still want them as
an adult but
i'm telling you that you can get a
cereal that's exactly like the ones you
love that has
zero sugar 11 grams of protein and only
three net carbs
in each serving if you were on a keto
diet
and you want to take a meal out of your
day and eat a bowl of
high protein cereal keto is very tough
very hard to plan
if you're on the go it can be incredibly
difficult here's the way you can do it
they have four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry it tastes amazing
honestly
too good to be true it's keto-friendly
gluten-free grain-free soy-free low-carb
gmo free
okay i love the fruity flavor tastes
exactly like fruit loops
so if you want to simulate a bowl of
fruit loops it's a great
no guilt dessert it's a meal replacement
it's a great breakfast it's a way to
give yourself a high protein low sugar
low carb snack no sugar sorry
low carb no sugar snack it works well
within the keto diet especially if
you're not doing any other carbs or
things that day
it's only three net grams of carbs so if
you're on a high protein diet this is
really the move
if you go to magicspoon.com tim dillon
to grab a variety pack and try it today
and if you like the show
and you want to support us and you want
to get a good cereal with no sugar in it
this is the way to do it magic spoon is
so confident in their product it's
packed with 100
happiness guarantee if you don't like it
for any reason they'll refund your money
no questions asked magic spoon is really
good they send me it all the time i eat
it it's good i like it i wouldn't lie
about that
and it is good you know me i'm on and
off diets all the time it's very
difficult
to keep your weight under control
especially in this [ __ ] country in
this economy
so that in this account
what is that does that come from the
standout bit
i think so when he's talking about
strengthening up your [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
it's so good
anyway we would go have him on the show
but he's too far away
we're not driving nine hours for that
we're not doing zoom with him um
so i mean we love magic spoon it's great
we thank magic spoon
for sponsoring the podcast and we hope
that you guys enjoy
their zero sugar high protein low carb
cereal
as much as we do so go to magicspoon.com
tim dillon magicspoon.com
tim dillon
here's the thing a lot of people put way
too much cologne on they mismatch a
cologne to their scent i'm telling you
right now
um you want a nice scent that is what
attracts people to each other pheromones
all that stuff
okay so what's great about hawthorne is
you kind of design your own cologne they
ask you a few questions about you
uh you take a quiz and what they have to
do is they kind of design a cologne
specifically for you
okay so where you live what you're into
what you do
all kinds of things go into this the
natural odors in the environment you're
in
they basically put together a per if
you've never had a personalized product
you might want to try one deodorant
shampoo body wash face cleanser lotion
they do it all at hawthorne they
personalize everything to you
everybody has different needs and
hawthorne understands that everybody has
different requirements
for the products they buy if you want to
achieve you know maximum success with
anything a cream
a lotion a potion whatever so if you
take a quick two minute quiz and
hawthorne tells you the two colognes
that are best for you
one for work and one for play totally
risk-free free shipping and free returns
check out hawthorne at hawthorne.co
that's hawthorne with an e
h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e with an e use my promo
code tim
get 10 off your first purchase
hawthorne.co
i'm telling you right now if you've not
had a personalized lotion
body wash face cleanser deodorant
cologne it's a game
changer truly this company will easily
design
something for you for your skin for your
scent
and i'm telling you right now it is very
very
uh luxurious you
feel luxurious you feel like the king of
england
you i'm the king of england i that's
what happens when you
use this face motion i'm the king of
england and everyone that doesn't look
or sound like me is a savage
and i'll now sound australian again i
can never do a good australian
except when i don't want to but on the
i'm the king of england because i have a
hawthorn
face lotion i'm the king of england and
i'm going to
christianize the barbarians so my point
is that which is
which is not good but colonization has
some benefit
the point is take the quiz go to
hawthorne put the lotion in the basket
right
isn't that what they said signs of lamb
put the lotion in the basket
that's what that's why i wouldn't be in
business because if i was hawthorne i
would
i would i'd be the guy in the room that
goes if if our if our
logo is not put the lotion in the bat
like if our logo is not
a hannibal lecter and if our uh if our
motto is not put the lotion in the
basket
what is it it puts a lotion on the skin
it puts the lotion
on itself if that's not our logo i don't
want to be involved with this company
that's my deal breaker hawthorne.co
use my promo code tim to get 10 of your
purchase
i did stand up for the second time at
whitney cummings house
whitney cummings uh had a stand-up
comedy show in her
driveway or her basketball court really
her driveway area
and uh it was a lot of fun
you know the all you know whitney knows
all these uh influencers
like these instagram is the proper term
hoes probably not i'm kidding ladies
but these instagram and well the teats
are out
i mean they're not influencing people to
go to school they're not doing a lot of
adult literacy programs from my
understanding
i'm sure they have many philanthropic
endeavors but
you know a lot of it is the teats are
out and uh and they all have like
deals you know they're hawking body oil
for millions and millions of dollars
on injury it's not my demo really
i like a working class philly from a
working class family from outside of
philly
i like a working class family from
outside of philly that begrudgingly has
to sit in a car together for 25 minutes
everyone's smoking cigarettes including
the dog
on the way to the show angry people
people that feel like they've been
slighted my audience is people that feel
like they've been
slighted like me because both of my
parents survived 9 11.
that's who my audience is so when i look
at these
hot instagram black lives matter
and you know all of these politically
correct
teats in the front row
um i i was like will i do well i don't
know but spade was there and whitney was
there and
the book or the comedy story was there
and some people were bombing by the way
you never really want to bomb when you
have people that you respect there but
some people just i mean
wow uh but most people doing great annie
letterman
murdered killed it very funny but
annie's like that she can kind of
[ __ ] bob and weave and really
you know when you're in a weird me and
annie came up in new york when we were
in a lot of weird situations
and you had to lend give yourself over
to that as a comedian and just go
we're in this [ __ ] up situation we're
going to call it out and then a lot of
other comedians get up there and they're
like
that that dang that day
have have you ever been to
have you ever and the crowd's like hey
we're instagram influencers we think
with our tits
what are you doing here can you [ __ ]
talk to us
can you [ __ ] i don't know who these p
olivia mun i don't even know who these
people are kesha who what's that
what's a ketchup i don't even know what
that is
is that like shakshouka
is that it's a dish who is this kesha
she said hello she because i'm kesha
like i'm gonna turn around i'm a huge
fan
she said that to me i had a peach in my
hand and i go do you think this is ripe
i was hitting it on the counter
[Music]
she's a singer apparently she did that
song tick tock
tick tock that was the song of every fat
freckled irish beast woman
who will still put it on facebook and be
like remember fridays
and college at suny new paltz that's my
girls
tech talk you know it was every fat
slobs theme song who was trying to get a
[ __ ] in their ass at 3am
at a suny school in new york freckled
irish beast women
would listen to that song that is what
you've inspired kesha yes or yes
that is what you have done that is what
you're me yes you want hot people
dancing to your music but it ain't
that's not the case
you know who loves that song me and a
wig me and a wig
and they'll still put it up on facebook
and they go hey this was a song from me
and my girls remember
girls and they tag all the other [ __ ]
hot air balloons that they went to a
suny school with
these [ __ ] boats that they went to
school with
i'm tagging all my girls and then you
just you just
you click on the the women that they've
tagged and it's just someone whose face
is like
you know the fat woman instagram shot
i've done it many times it's from up
here
up here tilted head that's fat woman
instagram up here tilted head you don't
know what's going on beneath my head
i bet it's hot though i bet it's a
cauldron of [ __ ] juice
that's what she did there's a place
downtown
tick tock tick tock that's your heart
ladies
kesha and then miranda cosgrove who's on
icarly i don't want a pedophile what is
this
i don't watch these things nickelodeon
drake and josh what are we nuts where
are the adults
where's candace owens
where is the exhumed corpse of william f
buckley i want to perform
what is icon did you watch this horse
[ __ ] when you were growing up you did
didn't you
rugrats yeah i carved i didn't have
cable i didn't have cable i come from
the mean streets
my parents survived 911. i didn't get
the good [ __ ]
i didn't get the jud apatow movies in
the cable
my parents didn't have their skin
[ __ ] melted
i like pizza i i don't know pete at all
i'm not i'm obviously i'm not throwing
any shade and pete
i know it's sad to have your dad killed
in 9 11.
but let's be very honest it's not worked
out horribly for him and this is the
fact so i'm willing to kill my parents
but this is what and kesha seemed like a
lovely woman
i they they all were lovely women i'm
not none of this i just this world is
i don't understand this world what is
icarly about
oh man it was a spin-off of drake and
josh and she lived in an apartment and
she had a
friend and a brother and they just got
into weird [ __ ] at school that was kind
of it
dude nickelodeon sucked the only good
things were
doug and daria they were [ __ ] good
they were [ __ ] good rugrats
fine was i would go to my friends houses
they had cable they had nickelodeon we
didn't have cable
when i was a kid i watched melrose place
i watched
sydney and michael carry on alert affair
and michael had a beach house in malibu
and then sydney blew up the whole
apartment complex
and i learned words like blackmail and
abortion
so i'm sorry i wasn't watching cartoon
children
you [ __ ] [ __ ] shout out to aaron
spelling and darren starr
melrose place is [ __ ] iconic shout
out to heather locklear i hope you're
okay wherever you are
you're probably parked on an off-ramp
somewhere but anyway i hope you're good
well she's had issues is what i'm saying
i don't know yes
she's probably parked somewhere on an
off ramp trying to figure out where she
is well we're with you in spirit heather
[ __ ] these kids i watched beverly hills
90210 and nypd blue
great shows dennis franz that fat racist
what a genius what an actor
i like and they all have this attitude
these hits these hot instagram people
have this attitude they're like
[Music]
that's how they talk like
i had to leave amanda cerny who i don't
know has got like a trillion followers
she got 25 million followers went up and
start re
starts reading whitney's act out of a
book
and i said and and and she's just sweet
girl you know i'm not
[ __ ] anybody here but i said that
was my time i looked at tom pop i said i
think it's time to go
tom papa brought a loaf of bread which i
just ate with my bare hands
in uh whitney's kitchen whitney's uh
whitney got some great pizza from big
mama's pizza
and i never had that and it was just
kind of like i don't know it's pretty
good
big mama and papa's pizzeria yeah it's
pretty good man she got cheese sticks
mozzarella sticks you don't find a lot
of mozzarella sticks in la
but when you got them and what's great
is i got to have pretty much all of the
food
because they don't eat the instagram
influencers don't eat
okay they don't eat they don't eat food
it's not allowed they take a picture
with an avocado once a month
and that's all the protein they need
so i was eating i was filling up but of
course some of the female comics are
filling up too you know they're not
exactly small
but it was a lot of fun it was an
interesting uh it was an interesting
time kesha didn't show up
sadly but she was there the other day
yeah i kid cash what do i know
she's you know so fast she seems like
such a mature
like almost dark
brooding type of person but then the
music is like
it's like an alarm clock or songs right
it's kind of like an alarm clock but
they're good but it's like a fun alarm
clock it's like
i'm i'm waking up tick-tock tip my life
means something
that's what her music is it's just fat
women in state schools going
we're making the memories
kidnap me please they want to get
kidnapped those women
someone take me away someone bury me
under a lake
show me that i'm special
[Laughter]
but i did well i had fun in the middle
of my set i said oh good crystal ages
got here
i said he'll go next that didn't get a
big chuckle
that was a ve that was not a warmly
received joke
there was a little chill in the air but
it was a good
thing whitney really loves stand-up
comedy and i think all these other women
really like her because whitney's
you know real deal comic kind of in that
boys club of being able to really throw
down really written whitney writes her
ass off
you know what i mean um um
and she just [ __ ] really does well
and her new jokes are very funny you
know what i mean
but then when she's like all right now
we're gonna have the instagram
influencers come up and do my material
and they're like
kids don't get injured anymore
have you heard that and the witness has
to explain to them she's like
well there's the premise comes first
honey the premise comes first and then
the punch line
don't no no no no don't snort the
microphone we talk
into it no we talk into it
um but i was uh i was really glad that i
was included now and now i'm sure i
won't be again
but content is king if i've learned one
thing its content
is king but it was very nice and she got
a lot of pizza i didn't even know
whitney knew what food
was because every time on there she was
always trying to give me like
plant-based
popsicles she's like this is a chocolate
kale pop
i'm like what she's like how about some
raspberry dust
i'm like wait what she never has regular
butter
she always has some weird butter she's
like this is butter from a cactus's
[ __ ]
and i'm like well how about how about a
cow
how about a cow's butter i didn't even
know she knew what [ __ ] dude if you had
said to me
whitney's having a comedy show and she's
getting food i would have never
thought that we were gonna be [ __ ]
doing pizza
cheese sticks garlic bread
how [ __ ] cool was that how unexpected
was that
i thought we were gonna be all eating
like you know like taking one bite of a
leaf and then handing it to the next
person
to bite it you know
but it was good man we hope the comedy
story opens we're back out on the road
having a little bit of fun
we are on the road we're going to be in
palm beach we're going gonna be in uh
in texas get get timberlandcomedy.com up
let's see where we're gonna be i'm
excited to be in some of these places
some of them not so much
so late september the 26th uh we're
gonna be at hyenas comedy club
in dallas october 1st through the 3rd
zany's in nashville
salt lake city wise guys october 6th and
7th
phoenix arizona stand up live the 9th
through the 11th of october tampa
florida side splitters
really i love that place october 20th
through wednesday the 21st west palm
beach florida
we're going to be there october 22nd
through the 24th so if you are in dallas
nashville salt lake city phoenix tampa
west palm
please grab your tickets they do go fast
these clubs are at
reduced capacity we also have some other
dates coming up maybe colorado
and places like that those are places
i'm very excited to go
those are places where i believe i don't
know about the coven numbers
poor i just turned out an offer for
portland just because the money wasn't
right
it's like i'm really not excited to do
it i know portland's a great comedy town
but it's like can you just get it
together a little bit over there
can you just get it together i don't
really need to [ __ ]
you know what do we what are we we were
riding every night now
said 12 days of christmas like the 60
days of looting
60 days of rioting just clean it up over
there portland please
i really don't like the pacific
northwest i i don't jive with it at all
i'll perform there but it's not for me
it's not for me
those [ __ ] great forests and
everything oh [ __ ] off
i'm it's not for me and if you live
there bless your heart and i know you
deserve comedy and maybe you're a fan of
the show
but i'll tell you right now i don't i do
not connect with your area at all
i went to spokane once which is
essentially a white supremacist i mean
it's like
they're literally like a few miles away
from this town in idaho where
everybody's like you know
real proud of their heritage got a lot
of interest in european culture
and uh you know i was like wow real
white crowd as soon as i walked onto the
stage of spokane and then everybody went
yeah the local races i was reading they
were like
uh governor bush otter is running
against and i'm like what are we doing
here
folks i was going nuts i was following
around a groundhog for two days this
groundhog i kept following around i
would facetime ben and show him the
groundhog
and uh and then i and then i realized
that a groundhog is the same thing as a
woodchuck
isn't that what i realized yeah or maybe
they're not the same or
or they are the same well why don't you
look it up this is why you're here
to look things up to be to be our link
to the to reality
a groundhog are also woodchucks
or a whistle pig or a land beaver now
that's what i learned vegans in spokane
i learned that i learned that a
groundhog
is also a woodchuck okay
i also learned several other things
about
you know genetics but i'll i'll leave
them out i'm also unsure of the
scientific basis of
much of what i was told much of what i
learned
but i i will get back to the pacific
northwest i'm just that excited to go
i'm not in
i'm not uh really pumped up
to go to the pacific northwest
those pale goth weirdos get the [ __ ] out
of here
expressvpn everybody needs a vpn and a
virtual private network why
it is you're able to disguise wherever
you are and you're going to need that
soon the government all these private
companies are all stealing your
information they want to know what
you're about
they're trying to kill you put a chip in
your head syringe in your ass you know
the deal
real prepper [ __ ] but now the prepper
stuff's starting to feel smart
one of the ways you can do it is by
disguising your location on the internet
vpns are incredibly important
do you want to watch cuties and peace
i'm kidding
i'm kidding i'm a comedian what i'm
saying is that you can use it to use
netflix from all over the world and see
uh you know the great japanese
bake off or whatever the hell is going
on so it creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so your online activity can't
be seen by anyone
it's as easy as closing the bathroom
door fire up the app and click one
button rated number one
buy wired the verge and cnet it works on
your phone laptops and even routers so
everyone who shares your wi-fi can be
protected
secure your online activity by visiting
tim expressvpn.com that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n and you can get an
extra three months free
expressvpn.com tim
dylan extra three months free i mean
that's 90 days of free
[ __ ] activity every i had no idea how
big vpns were
i had no idea you gotta have a vpn i'm
using it on the laptop right now it is
so important also i had no idea the of
the hivs
you got to get so you could get an hiv
and a vpn i had no idea how
how prevalent those two things were
hiv now is not even a huge deal by the
way no one cares age is less than
covent you you hope you go you go i open
a veins um
so if you go that's expressvpn.com it's
a great way to support the show you've
got to get one of these anywhere you're
getting three months off
do you care you're not finding something
else with three months off all these
[ __ ] have enough money
help me expressvpn.com
slash tim dillon t-i-m-t-i-l-l-o-n it is
as easy as closing the bathroom door
fire up the app and click one button how
easy is that
i mean it's very easy yes or
yes expressvpn dot com slash
tim dillon the tim dillard show is
sponsored by manscape keeping your body
groomed
and tidy is important it makes you feel
better do yourself a favor and get the
right tools for the job get manscaped
the only brand dedicated to below the
belt grooming the engineers at manscape
created the perfect ball hair trimming
system
it's called the perfect package and it
comes with the lawnmower 3.0 the best
trimmer on the market it's waterproof
and cordless so you can use it in the
shower
and it has a contoured design that makes
it easy to navigate your most sensitive
area
their proprietary skin save technology
makes it nearly impossible to cut
yourself god shaving so hard
as always the perfect package comes with
a crop preservative anti-chafing bowl
deodorant moisturizer
and the crop reviver ph balance for
freshness subscribe and get a new
replacement blade every three months
plus get two free gifts the shed travel
bag which is a very nice bag 39
value and the patented high performance
reduced chafing manscaped
boxer briefs this is the perfect package
for your
perfect package get 20
offering free shipping when you use the
code tim d at manscape.com that's
manscape.com use promo code timd
for 20 off your first order your balls
will thank you
i'm excited to go to london i want to go
to london let's sell out to soho theater
i want to go to the uk
i want to do that true jordy podcast
that guy i want to eat
meat pies you know i want to eat good
chicken tikka masala which is the
cuisine of london you know
because what what is it going to be
boiled meat
you know they have that uh sunday roast
in england they're all talking about how
good it is
with the yorkshire pudding and the roast
so there's like you know british people
would come over here and they'd be like
there's nothing better than the sunday
roast it's just not better
i'm like yeah uh you know what's better
than that a chicken finger
in my country a mall chicken finger is
better than your national dish shut the
[ __ ] up
you gave us a lot of great gifts like
civilization racism
but you don't you don't you don't you
don't have anything going on with the
food
we don't need your [ __ ] yorkshire
pudding
and yeah it's just gray roast beef it's
fine i'm sure it's
good damn good if it's done right but
they're so invested that it's the best
it's the best thing ever it's nothing
better than a sunday roast
uh yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna say a combos
are
i'm gonna say uh combos from a truck
stop that you eat on the way to a
national park you're gonna get kidnapped
in
are better than your sunday road you're
graying
your gray [ __ ] lip roast beef and your
yorkshire [ __ ] pudding and your
mashed peas grow the [ __ ] up
and your somebody was talking to me
about this and i forgot
who was talking to me about it but
somebody made a great point they were
like i might have been on another show
they were saying like isn't it weird
that britain's big fish and chips dish
is served in like newspaper
and they serve it with like malt vinegar
it's very strange
you know but they come over here they
are impressed by our food over here
that's one thing in america really
impresses people
i mean we don't have much else going on
except spectacle we're very good at
spectacle
is that kim kardashian you know like
they're all into that like oh my god
that's a person from tv and they're
they're real
and they're actually here that that we
can do
really well you know but uh food is just
r
you know there's no there's no more
sinful
food than america nobody lays a meal on
you
like america even italy you feel light
and fine after you eat
but america we poison people truly with
everything we give
them just a little bit of poison you
know and uh
the people from the uk are like stunned
you go go have a milkshake in another
country for mcdonald's you're like this
is like not sweet
and then you realize that part of what
makes our milkshakes sweet is the amount
of syrup that goes into them
and that's why you're drinking them and
you get a pounding headache
about 30 minutes after you have this
milkshake because you're coming down
after you have the milk check you're in
the car you're like
my life's gonna work out
everything's gonna be okay frappuccino
milkshake any of it
i'm gonna be i'm doing well when you
have a frappuccino when you're halfway
down
a starbucks frappuccino and you're in
the front of your car and you got the
air conditioning blasting on your face
and you got that frappuccino down and
your and you got the caffeine in there
and then the sugar
you're going okay i can do this whatever
this is whatever this life is i can do
it
and then 30 minutes later you have a
pounding
headache because you're coming down from
the sugar and you need something else
so you stuff a thing of gum in you take
a [ __ ] energy try i mean it's just a
never-ending
you know so i want to get over there i
want to get over there to australia to
the uk
and do some of those markets i'm very
excited about
going to those markets and i've never
done stand-up i've done stand-up comedy
in scotland
which was great i went over with a
mixed-race comic and an indian woman
and then i walked out and like all the
scottish people were like oh is the
american
like they were like oh here's the
there's a reason trump got elected
you know because like the two comedians
i went with were fairly woke
so they went out they did like their
woke bits and the crowd's like okay
this is this the american showcase
and then i went out and i was like hey
[ __ ] you and they were like
yeah and we just connected i love that
room the stand in glasgow
great i don't know what's happening to
uk comedy i imagine like american comedy
is being pulverized into the ground by
uh you know non-binary fat witches
running around
uh telling people casting spells on
people and telling them what words
they're
allowed to utter i'm unsure god i just
want to go
can we just go back to a [ __ ] nice
time of private kind of puritanical
set like sex should be private sex is
by its nature better if it's private you
know what i mean
and and i know what you're saying that's
what epstein thought but i don't mean it
like
that what i mean is that by making sex
just mass marketing and vulgar
and nasty what you're doing is you're
taking all the
interesting kind of cool stuff about it
away and you're making
it this transactional [ __ ]
you know experience that you know
me people are having less sex isn't it
amazing think about that
wet ass [ __ ] is one of the biggest
songs in the country people are actually
coming in contact with less wet ass
[ __ ] in real life
they're having less sex they're
furiously masturbating to porn
they're not having a lot of sex because
everything's been digital and
everything's been made very sterile
sex feels very sick have you ever met a
sex addict
and heard them talk about sex when they
talk about it it sounds
gross because they talk about it the way
that you talk about anything you do all
the time that is relatively kind of me
someone meaningless to you and and it's
very a perfunctory
uh the mechanization of it the the
mechanics of it
the way they talk about it they talk
about it in a way where you go oh it
just sounds kind of gross because
instinctually we know that sex should
have some level of it
doesn't always have to be this special
amazing whatever thing but it should
have something about it
that is more than pissing sex should be
more than pissing and [ __ ]
we know that but when a sex addict talks
to you about sex it sounds like
somebody's talking about taking a piss
it does and then i stopped behind the
rest stop and the bathroom was out so i
just took a piss around the building
then i got back in my car and i drank
some more water [ __ ] i had to piss again
so i pissed in a bottle then i kept
driving
in the hotel room and i pissed all of it
i was so drunk i pissed all over the
[ __ ] bed
piss pissed piss a piss in the ocean a
piss in the pool
all right why are you telling me but
there's something
kind of antiseptic sterile medical
gross about that and i feel like our
society is heading to that place
with sex and it's very it is disturbing
when you see
young kids young girls and boys
sexualized
before they are mature enough to handle
the emotional psychological
ramifications of their behavior and what
they're doing
you know so when you have these girls
dancing like this they don't know they
don't know who finds that attractive
they're not ready to handle that they're
not ready to handle what they're doing
and
it's just to me i i i'm deeply
conservative kind of
when it comes to i want to live and meet
me in st
louis meet me in st louis was a it was a
musical with judy garland
uh respect pills and booze respect
and meet me in st louis look at the
house they lived in
i like these outfits that the people are
in
that's the way people should dress and
they took trolleys
and the woman and the women could look
at these women
that's not unattractive and look at the
men
and the women look a little trans and
that's fine
that was nice back there gender was more
fluid then than it is
now you keep injecting collagen
into your [ __ ] lips to make yourself
look these people were cut look at that
one on the left she's kind of like
who knows what's going on there but it's
fun
and they did look at that people used to
dance with top hats and canes go up
there to the left
look at the way people used to live what
year was this
in 1944 1944
not everything going on in 1944 was
spectacular
it's an unfortunate year for this to
have been made i'm in a little bit of a
hall now
okay what i'm saying
is that i don't like anything about 1944
except this film
i didn't know when it was made when i
went into this i don't prepare for this
[ __ ] show
there was a lot going on in 1944 that i
have a big
problem with but people taking trolleys
in st
louis and dancing with hats is not one
of them
christ it had to be made in 1944
now it sounds like a dog whistle i'm
going to have to deal with that daily
show writer again
she did have yourself a you know have
yourself a merry little christmas
this was the famous song that came from
meet me in st louis my
my grandmother used to watch this and
then clank clan clang went to trolley
did you ever listen to that no i didn't
clank clan clang went to trolley
ding ding ding went to bell whatever is
going on in germany
is their business now that lyric was
changed
let's not ask too many questions stocks
are up things are going well
[Music]
but this was a this was a fun i mean
this was fun here
did you see this did you watch the
classics never seen this
never seen this
this was a great [ __ ] man have
yourself a merry
a look a merry little christmas
take the vikings
booze and pills and you know that was
judy garland
towards the end it was rough but she was
a [ __ ] icon she had that voice she
was in the wizard of oz
yes and she had that before she had that
amazing voice that nobody had you know
that remember that
keeping up with the kardashians is
ending let's pull that up keeping up
with the kardashians is ending
folks and it is one of the most
influential shows of the last 25 years
it is the blueprint for modern american
fame
100 okay
it replaced talent with access and this
point
is uh something that we we've seen
over and over again access
caitlyn jenner nobody called you [ __ ]
no one's calling you
caitlyn caitlin is like
the most hilarious problematic trans
woman ever
she's so great she's like nobody called
me i was at a trump rally i had service
said caitlyn no one's calling you're out
of control caitlyn
caitlin's like talk i'm on tour with
candace owens and no one called me
i don't get it i heard it on the news
why can't one of the kids that i have
that might be o.j simpson's call me
but this is what this is what american
fame has become it's access you sell
access to yourself
and the cooler life you have the more
people want access to it right so if you
live in calabasas
and you're rich and you have celebrity
friends people really want access to
that
or if you're a tick tocker and you live
in one of those houses people want
access to that but they don't care about
talent you do you care about talent
but the others don't um we're talking
about
mass marketing here and the way that
it's done
people want in they want in they want to
see behind the curtain behind the veil
they want to feel like they're sitting
in your living room they want to watch
you eat uh cheerios
this is what has been happening over the
last
you know two decades in this country we
have replaced talent the things that
judy garland had which is this one in a
million voice
that was really never replicated that
just rolled out of her mouth like this
crazy
[ __ ] you know when you hear her do
somewhere over the rainbow or you hear a
do
have yourself a merry little christmas
it wasn't a it was it was it wasn't even
remarkably powerful she wasn't really
uh you know she didn't belt she belt it
out a little but nothing compared to
like whitney houston or somebody like
that
but it was just this voice it it wasn't
from training
it wasn't really from it was just there
it was this thing inside of her that
just came out it was this gift whatever
you want to call it it was like
from some other [ __ ] celestial realm
when she was really hitting that
we're not interested in that anymore
in this in fact we think that's weird we
kind of don't like that
we kind of don't like when someone has
an unexplainable
amazing talent because we don't know how
we're going to do it
we don't know how we fit into that
well i got a wacky family and maybe one
day you know there's always this weird
idea
that you're vicariously living through
all these people that you watch on tv
and you think there's a possibility that
you might become them
and and there's just no way to do that
when you have somebody that has this
incredibly rare
talent that really isn't i'm sure judy
garland worked hard but let's be very
honest
that's a very natural kind of talent
kind of masculine
husky voice like what go go to uh can we
even play
any of this uh you want to play music i
want to play
have yourself a merry little christmas
yeah i'd probably get pulled get pulled
right yeah yeah
well spotify your move write to check
daddy'll dance right over you write that
check
but what i'm saying is that the
kardashians are the
are the blueprint for being famous now
that's what aoc is a kardashian
yeah the hype house and the sway house
are kardashians
all the major political figures now will
be kardashians donald trump's a
kardashian
don't get it twisted everything that's
succeeding right now
in a very big way are kardashians
they they're those are people that give
you
it's an all-access pass to their
thoughts and their lives
no matter how humdrum and unimportant
something they may be doing is they'll
do it and they'll let you in on it
and that and you get the access pass you
all access pass all day every day you
can
sit there and have a ringside seat for
uh
their life and again the cooler the life
is or the more
uh sensational it is the more people
want in
and that's what the kardashians did
that's really what the kardashians did
it's it's it's really amazing to watch
uh a show like this coming to an end
because you don't know what's next
you know get one of the kids from one of
the guys from chapel trap
has after trump won i think he said but
the really scary thing is you like what
is next
you can't imagine what's next i can't
imagine what is next
after the kardashian you know i can't
imagine how it could get
less talent focused truly
and i like them by the way i've defended
them i like them i think they're hard
work
that kim kardashian's a beast and a
business person
and there's no uh i have nothing
negative to say about them
other than the um
celebration of that particular
type of show um and that particular type
of
route to fame is
says a lot about the wholesale
destruction of the american culture
that but that's the only negative thing
i'd say truly
and if you know me you know i could say
a lot of negative things the only
negative thing that i would say is that
it's the wholesale destruction of
any beauty in american culture
but other than that truly truly other
than that
i kind of respect the hustle yeah here's
what america is i said this on the sagar
pod but it's not coming out to the week
before the election so
here's what it is if i had to explain
america to somebody
america is hearing a song
on the radio and then somebody tells you
that song is bad
baby and you go who's bad baby and they
go it's the woman who said that catch me
aside
the woman who's threatening to fight the
audience and her own mother on dr
phil and there's a moment of rage that
builds up in you that this woman is now
a star
but then a split second later you start
bobbing your head to the beat and you go
this isn't that bad
this isn't that bad america is the
moment
between the rage and going
this is pretty good that's where america
lives
never forget that so as angry as i may
seem
or as hateful as some of my
rhetoric appears a minute later i'll
just go
pretty good because i'm a survivor and
that's how you survive in america that's
how you don't go insane
that's how you don't go and say because
otherwise you just go insane
you bang your head against the wall
until you see blood
you know just that moment of i can't
believe this [ __ ]
[ __ ] i don't know about these house
it's the moment this
she's a [ __ ] is a why porsche yj's
why oh well this isn't that bad at
all that's america and that's the way i
feel about the cardiac
because for a moment i get
a little angry that the beauty
of american culture
any of it has been completely
and totally destroyed
to never return
that bothers me a little bit but it's
not the worst show
goodbye